If you wanna make everyone fall in love with you..
here's what you should do!
this one thing will help you make friends
and build stronger connections with other people.
When people first meet other people
and they're trying to have a conversation
they'll either go one of two routes
A) they relate it back to themselves
or B) ask a question about what they just told you
People think that relating things is a good thing,
but here's why it's actually not.
When you wanna get to know people
that's not actually what you want to do
You wanna talk about them.
Most people love talking about themselves
people love to hear their name
they love to brag
if you allow someone to do this
they'll fall in love with you
Next time someone is trying to share something about themselves to you
instead of relating it back to yourself
try asking them questions
for example if someone said they really enjoyed their dinner last night
Instead of saying “oh, I did too I really liked my dinner last night”
what you can do instead is ask some questions
what did you cook? did you order out?
what kind of food was it? what did you really like about it?
Stop relating everything back to you
if you want to really get to know people and build stronger connections
Because people love to talk about themselves
It’s the easiest way when you meet someone
go up to them and ask them questions
it'll make them feel seen, heard and you'll make them feel truly special
that is the key to building strong connections in your life.